bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24 au
Brésil Lula et bolsonaro s'affronteront
donc le 30 octobre prochain pour le
second tour c'est bien sûr un revers
pour l'ancien président de gauche qui se
retrouve en ballotage même s'il est en
tête au premier tour et devant son rival
de 5 points les sondages se sont donc
trompés sur l'ampleur des soutiens de
bolsonaro selon les résultats définitifs
vous le voyez Lula récolte 48,4% des
voix contre
43,2% pour bolsonaro le Brésil est coupé
en deux vous le voyez sur cette carte
avec un or plutôt justement acquis à
Lula et à Sud à qui à bolsonaro au
premier tour Lula est donc en tête dans
trois états qui avaient choisi bolsonaro
en 2018 comme le minage et rice
l'amazona ou encore lamapa mais dans les
grands États du Sud bolsonaro l'emporte
à Sao Paulo Rio Grande et Dols soul
s'ouvre donc une nouvelle période de
campagne qui va durer quatre semaines et
qui pourrait bien sûr être tendu alors
d'abord comment expliquer le score de
bolsonaro peut-il l'emporter au second
tour le bolsonarisme est-il ancré dans
le pays quelle campagne fera Lula pour
gagner contre son rival bolsonaro
contestera-t-il les résultats s'il perd
au second tour Brésil un second tour à
haut risque et bien on en parle avec mes
invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes
côtés mariage José Malraux bonsoir vous
êtes militante du Parti des Travailleurs
brésiliens donc le parti de Lula
bienvenue à vous et bienvenue dans tes
bas bien sûr Carlos Kenan bonjour vous
êtes économiste vice-président de
l'Institut des Amériques professeurs à
la Sorbonne Nouvelle bonsoir également
bienvenue dans le débat Jean-Jacques
courlian ski bonsoir directeur de
l'observatoire de l'Amérique latine à la
Fondation Jean Jaurès chercheur à l'Iris
et puis donc vous avez publié ce cet
ouvrage progressiste et Démocratie en
Amérique latine de 2000 à 2021 donc 21
ans de progressisme merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous nous avons avec nous
donc notre correspondante Fanny Lother
Fanny bonsoir avant de vous faire réagir
Fanny parce que vous allez ouvrir ce
débat pour nous donner un petit peu la
température sur le terrain d'abord
retour sur les soirées électorales c'est
avec
Elliott Samuel
dans les rues de Sao Paulo c'est
supporter de Lula laissent s'éclater
leur joie leurs candidat est bien en
tête du premier tour avec un score
retour de 48% des voix mais
l'ex-président de gauche va donc devoir
passer par un second tour ce qu'il
espérait éviter et surtout l'actuel chef
de l'État gerbolsenaro n'est pas si loin
5 points derrière les sondages donnés
pourtant un écart qui allait parfois
jusqu'à 14 points qu'importe Lula se dit
persuadé qu'il l'emportera
j'ai toujours cru que nous allions
gagner ces élections
et ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
nous allons gagner ces élections
c'est juste un délai supplémentaire pour
nous
le report des voies notamment celle du
candidat de centre gauche sirogomet
semble favorable à Lula mais dans le
camp de jaillir bolsonaro l'espoir reste
total le score bien plus élevé que prévu
du président brésilien a galvanisé ses
supporters le président brésilien y
croit plus que jamais et n'a pas manqué
de tacler les instituts de sondage
nous avons vaincu les mensonges des
sondages nous allons de l'avant tout est
remis à égalité maintenant nous allons
encore mieux montrer ce que l'on peut
faire pour le peuple brésilien
je pense que nous formerons une bonne
alliance pour gagner les élections
l'affrontement entre les deux hommes
s'annoncent plus que temps durant les
quatre prochaines semaines avant un
second tour prévu le 30 octobre prochain
tour sera le combat de Dieu contre la
corruption la liberté de Jaïre bolsonaro
contre la censure de Lula
j'espère que Lula l'emporterait dès le
premier tour pour ne pas avoir à
supporter ce gouvernement pendant un
mois de plus mais je suis forcé de
reconnaître qu'il y a aussi plein de
gens qui ne pensent pas comme moi
à Rio le climat a l'air d'être
électrique alors qu'on en est qu'au tout
début des quatre semaines de campagne
qui s'ouvrent
oui c'est un Brésil extrêmement polarisé
qui se réveille ce lundi matin d'un côté
des sympathisants de gauche qui vous
l'avez vu on la victoire amer seulement
5 points d'écart avec le président
candidat gerbossonaro il s'attendait à
beaucoup plus c'est en tout cas ce que
les sondages elles prédisaient une
victoire dès le premier tour et on les
sent un petit peu lassé fatigué de faire
campagne c'est une campagne qui a été
d'une rare violence ils sont fatigués
aussi de ces quatre dernières années de
gouvernement gère lozenaro qu'ils
accusent d'avoir isolé le pays sur la
scène internationale d'avoir détruit son
économie ou encore détruit fragilisés
ces institutions démocratiques de
l'autre côté et des partisans de gerbe
sur la route qu'on a rencontré ce matin
dans le quartier de Copacabana quartier
plutôt bourgeois cossus des
sympathisants qui eux aussi sont dépités
semblent dépité parce qu'il croyait eux
aussi à une victoire dès le premier tour
balayant évidemment elle les institut de
sondage pour lesquelles ils montent le
Subaru leur avait promis une victoire
pers vous voyez que elle est foule qui
se rassemblent à chacun de ces meetings
faisaient preuve du nombre d'électeurs
qu'il allait gagner le jour du premier
tour et puis on les sent quand même un
petit peu content parce que et ils se
sont rendus compte qu'ils avaient réussi
à gagner une majorité au Congrès et ça
ça va permettre à leur président ainsi
les réélu de pouvoir mieux gouverner lui
qui avait souvent critiqué le pouvoir
législatif qui l'empêchait de gouverner
on sent donc une extrême polarisation et
on voit que les deux candidats sont déjà
prêts à parcourir à sillonner le pays
pour faire campagne et convaincre les
indécis mais surtout convaincre et c'est
très étonnant dans un pays où le vote
est obligatoire les prêts de 20% de
Brésiliens qui se sont abstenus de voter
merci Fanny Fanny Lotter donc un autre
correspondante à Rio mariage José Mallet
rose est-ce que Lula a commis des
erreurs pendant cette campagne
bon parce qu'on voit qu'ils sont déçus
évidemment à ceux qui ont dans les
sondages l'annonçaient quasiment
victorieux au premier tour oui tout
d'abord je voulais parler de ces
problèmes de sondages en effet les
sondages disaient que là pouvait avoir
autour de 50% des voix la dernière
semaine
effectivement les sondages
savent ceux qui connaissent les sondages
savent qu'il y a toujours une marge la
marge d'erreur qui était normalement de
2% donc ce point de vue là par rapport à
la le sondages
ne se sont pas trompés du tout le la
reste dans la marge d'erreur
48,4%, ça reste dans la marche
[Musique]
ils se sont peut-être sont trompés sur
bolsonaro mais il y a aussi les faits
que
les médias les grands médias en parlant
tous les jours que Lula allait vaincre
au premier tour chose qui on ne voit
jamais un scrutant majoritaire qui est
un candidat qui arrive gagne au premier
tour sauf si c'est une élection donc là
on peut voir mais
c'est il n'y a pas commis d'erreur lors
de cette campagne vous pensez enfin il y
avait pas il a beaucoup pacsé sa
campagne sur cet âge d'or peut-être que
la trop fait sur ce passé
oh non il a parlé du passé mais il a
parlé du présent et du futur surtout
parce que les Brésiliens aujourd'hui
sont inquiets pour leur futur c'est ça
le problème mais je ne vois pas
d'erreurs majeures qui méritent d'être
souligné Carlos Canada est-ce que le
bolsonarisme est solidement ancré au
Brésil est-ce qu'il est devenu une sorte
de mouvement de fond au sein de la
société brésilienne oui je le pense
c'est d'ailleurs pas une caractéristique
seulement brésilienne c'est-à-dire dans
le monde occidental dans les contextes
d'un ralentissement de la croissance qui
dure déjà et c'est qui précède les
éléments récents n'est-ce pas des crises
énergétiques alimentaires liées à
l'invasion de la Russie vous avez un
ancrage des mouvements d'extrême droite
on a vu en Italie récemment il y a Vox
qui reprend qui prend force en Espagne
en revenant la période de Franco la
Suède on a vu Trump également donc je
pense que c'est un mouvement
si c'est sans doute c'est assez proche
de ça avec les spécificités propres du
Brésil et dans un contexte d'anxiété
disons
des des peurs qui qu'il y a concernant
l'instance altitude qui caractérise
comme je disais de nombreux secteurs
sociaux dans le monde occidental
notamment et malgré son bilan
Jean-Jacques rourianzky malgré son bilan
sur le covid quand même 680 000 morts il
a fait un score effectivement qui est
quand même très important dans le saunao
très important je crois qu'il faut
revenir un petit peu en arrière on a
beaucoup parlé des sondages et on
analyse le résultat la victoire
finalement de l'Ola qui est arrivé au
premier tour comme un échec en la
confrontant à ce que ce qu'avant c'est
ce qu'annoncer les sondages donc
l'erreur peut-être de Lula et de de son
équipe et d'avoir surestimer les
sondages d'avoir vendu la peau de l'ours
avant de de l'avoir tué
effectivement bolsonaro bénéficie d'un
soutien comme le dit Carlos Kenan est
important dans la population brésilienne
qui a plusieurs explications c'est pas
simplement un vote de classe moyenne
Classe C il y a également une présence
du bolsonarible dans les classes
populaires il s'appuie qu'elle reflet du
réseau des des pasteurs n'ont pas
évangélistes comme on dit souvent mais
pentecôtiste ce différent de la théorie
les évangéliques que les adventistes et
les baptistes et les méthodistes c'est
le protestantisme traditionnel je dirais
les nouveaux évangélistes sur les
pentecôtistes qui défendent une
théologie dite de la prospérité qui
s'appuie sur la le fait que gagner de
l'argent et bien vu par le CE par Dieu
par ceux qui sont au-dessus et donc les
pasteurs évangélistes défendent
cette théorie là qui est du
ruissellement de l'argent des plus
riches vers les plus pauvres ils
défendent la famille ils sont ils ont
fait des émules au Brésil suffisamment
pour justement donner gagnant bolsonaro
c'est une religion qui se substitue
progressivement catholicisme qui est
déjà majoritaire dans l'État de Rio qui
est l'état de bolsonaro et qui
représente 30% de la population
brésilienne si vous ajoutez à cela une
campagne de dénigrement et de fausses
nouvelles déjà été utilisé en 2018 par
exemple l'une des fausses nouvelles qui
a été diffusée c'est le lien qui aurait
Corée Lula avec une des principales
organisations de délinquant à San Paolo
le PCC le premier commando de la
capitale bon ce sont des fausses
nouvelles
mais qui comme la plupart des Brésiliens
ne lisent pas le journal regarde assez
peu la télévision la source
d'information principale en dehors du
pasteur ce sont les réseaux sociaux et
WhatsApp avec les techniciens mode
chariot vous êtes vous nous avez rejoint
vous êtes historienne spécialiste du
Brésil contemporain directrice de
l'ouvrage mon cher Loula lettre à un
président en détention c'est aux
éditions anamosa merci beaucoup de nous
rejoindre puisque vous êtes justement à
Rio sur place est-ce que vous pouvez
rebondir sur ce que vient de dire
Jean-Jacques courlian ski est-ce que
vous avez l'impression qu'il y avait
beaucoup de fake news beaucoup de
fausses informations pendant cette
campagne qui aura été en fait favorable
à bolsonaro
c'est une évidence et c'est en partie ce
qui explique la surprise des secteurs
progressistes face aux résultats de
bolsonaro il y a une conviction dans les
secteurs progressistes que le bilan
catastrophique de bolsonaro tend sur la
pauvreté les inégalités la gestion de la
pandémie avec des scandales de
corruption absolument massifs sur
l'utilisation des vaccins ne pouvait que
avoir pour conséquence la réduction du
vote bolsonaro à un vote presque
fanatique qui ne pouvait pas dépasser un
certain pourcentage et le problème c'est
que toute une partie de l'opinion et de
l'opinion des élites politiques du monde
journalistique n'a pas accès à
l'information qui est celle qui qui est
touchée qui touche les gens qui votent
bolsonaro et qui effectivement n'est pas
vraiment un espace public qui est un
espace semi public comme l'a dit
Jean-Jacques rourianski fait de réseau
de différents réseaux WhatsApp mais
aussi d'autres réseaux de messagerie qui
permet à des gens d'avoir de vivre dans
des bulles d'information absolument
séparées de une relation générale et qui
avait propagé l'information selon
laquelle bolsonaro allait gagner au
premier tour l'idée c'était les 70
millions de votes que bolsonaro allait
forcément recevoir et ces personnes là
qui ont accès à cette information là ont
aussi une représentation absolument
distincte de ce qu'a fait bolsonaro qui
peut être représenté comme quelqu'un qui
défend les droits des femmes qui n'a
jamais fait autant que personne pour les
catégories populaires et donc le Brésil
d'aujourd'hui c'est un Brésil qui est
extrêmement divisé extrêmement polarisé
le vote de premier tour qui ressemble en
fait à un vote de second tour le montre
mais c'est aussi un Brésil qui est
complètement ségrégué sur l'information
à laquelle les différentes parties de la
population ont accès qui vivent dans des
mondes différents dans des mondes
d'information dans des mondes de valeurs
complètement différents et la grande le
grand enjeu maintenant du second tour
mais ensuite des années c'est de comment
est-ce qu'on fait vivre de nouveau
ensemble ces populations là comment
est-ce qu'on les réintègre dans un même
rapport à la politique dans un même
rapport état dans un même rapport à la
sécularisation de la Vie dans la Cité et
pour l'instant il n'y a pas vraiment de
réponse à ça il y a deux Brésil qui
communiquent bientôt pu et qui sont par
ailleurs dans une relation de
brutalisation de violence énormément à
l'initiative d'une partie des militants
de bolsonaro qui considèrent que autre
chose que leur propre position qui est
la position de la vérité de la
légitimité et du peuple n'a plus le
droit d'exister et c'est ce qui est très
dangereux dans les quatre semaines à
venir parce que de fait Lula est plutôt
encore dans une position favorable
malgré la déception par rapport au
sondage mais les 45% 44% de la
population qui ont voté bolsonaro pour
partie considère comme impossible
inacceptable et illégitime le fait que
l'autre moitié puisse s'exprimer et
gagner la présidence on pourrait avoir
une sorte de scénario à la Trump on va y
revenir Marie-José maleros un mot quand
même sur ces troisièmes voies il y a
quand même une troisième une quatrième
position à cette présidentielle Simone
Simone on dit je crois tu es bête donc
qui a obtenu 4% centre droit et puis
sirop Gomes donc qui lui a obtenu 3% ils
vont être courtisés par j'imagine Lula
comment ça va se passer parce que s'ils
ont un report de voix sur Loula là ça
peut vraiment être favorable évidemment
aux candidat de gauche
oui je pense que oui dans le cas de la
troisième voie qui était souhaitée
surtout par le grand capital n'était pas
du tout silogo Simone voulait une autre
personne ils ont essayé plusieurs ils
n'ont rien eu donc ils sont restés ils
se sont accommodés des bolsonaro
l'acceptation de Luna il y a un côté
idéologique qu'on préfère bon l'écarter
bien que ces capitales a gagné
énormément d'argent
sur le gouvernement lu là la sirogomme
ce qui a choisi la voie de plutôt
lu là et le groupe de Lula et de faire
une campagne où il était plutôt presque
en collectif de bolsonaro
c'est qui a fait penser peut-être à ces
électeurs qui étaient estimé entre 7 et
même 9 10 % que bon puisque la guerre
était entre bolsonaro il fallait mieux
peut-être de voter tout de suite pour
sonaru et donc
il y a eu mais ils vont être courtisé
j'imagine par les deux et est-ce qu'ils
vont plutôt est-ce que les ceux qui ont
voté donc un soit pour sirop soit pour
tes bêtes vont plutôt reporter leur voix
sur Lula ou plutôt sur bolsonaro et ça
monte hein
mais tout c'est que c'est passé dans les
rapports entre le la et sirugombes dû
aux attaques de sérigum je vois mal lu
là elle est courtiser si le gomme cette
différence de courtes et ses électeurs
et donc du coup qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez Carlos Kenan il pourrait y avoir
un report sur bolsonaro plutôt là
et un complément de ce qui vient de te
dire si logo mais c'est par exemple lors
des élections de 2018 avait eu 12 % de
voix on le crédit maintenant de 8 9 donc
la question est de savoir cette partie
qui se reportée est verbale il y a
peut-être une petite partie aussi qui se
reporté vers où là parce que électorat
plutôt progressiste qui pourrait être
suivi par silogomme c'est pas l'histoire
etc il faut mais la question c'est que
et c'est c'est probablement un noyau qui
serait comme on dit le difficile à à
convaincre sur la base d'arguments la
question que qui est très importante
aussi à signaler c'est que il y a
beaucoup d'émotions
des voix non rationnelles que l'on voit
dans d'autres comme dans d'autres pays
d'ailleurs qu'on a évoqué et donc on
peut pas en parler d'un report rationnel
des trois poissons facile et d'appeler
aux intérêts y en a beaucoup des disons
d'appels aux émotions surtout évidemment
dans la perspective de bolsonaro donc
c'est un certain c'est vrai que nous la
bien placé parce qu'il a le finalement
il lui reste peu pour arriver à la
majorité mais c'est pas gagné du tout
d'avance parce qu'il faut voir ce que
l'on a évoqué aussi les réseaux sociaux
le fake news plein de choses qui peuvent
intervenir et qui peuvent faire exploser
une bombe ou quelque chose considéré
comme tel et qui pourrait changer la
donne on peut gagner
c'est une hypothèse
c'est vrai que il suffit à Lula d'avoir
la moitié des 7% des voix gagnées par le
troisième et le quatrième candidat mais
comme ça cela vient d'être dit ces
reports ne sont pas évidents donc il est
possible même probable que Lula lance un
appel peut-être pas sirogomes mais au
pdt un appel à la raison démocratique et
non pas voter pour lui ou à voter pour
le péter ou pour l'Alliance et qui
soutient Lula mais pour défendre la
démocratie
est-ce que ces électeurs vont suivre
est-ce que que va dire si on Gomes il
faut rappeler qu'en 2018 déjà il était
candidat donc il avait fait 12%. donc
qu'est-ce qu'il allait faire de ses 12%
entre les deux tours il a choisi de les
geler il est venu se reposer à Paris il
n'a pas fait campagne pour le candidat
du péton
Metz pourrait appeler à voter Lula sauf
alors la seule hypothèse possible c'est
que le parti dont il est le candidat lui
considère que l'intérêt du Pdt c'est
plutôt de soutenir Lula donc le péter
les travailleurs pdt c'est le capital et
les paroles
chirio tout de même sur les postes de
gouverneur parce qu'il y a évidemment
cette élection présidentielle et puis il
y a eu les élections à la chambre un
tiers également de sénateurs qui ont été
renouvelés et puis il y a les
gouverneurs et c'est intéressant de voir
peut-être cette bataille assez
représentatives peut-être qui est celle
du gouverneur du poste de gouverneur
Sao Paulo entre donc Freitas qui est
l'ancien Miss de l'infrastructure de
bolsonaro qui est arrivé en tête devant
donc Fernando Haddad qui était le
dauphin qui est le dauphin de de Lula et
qui pensait pas justement qu'il serait
battu alors il va y avoir un second tour
pour ces deux hommes est-ce qu'ils sont
pas un peu représentatifs justement de
cette division dont vous parliez et puis
finalement ils sont quand même beaucoup
d'accoude dans une très grande ville qui
est vraiment le pôle économique du
Brésil à Sao Paulo
essentiel ce scrutin pour ce poste de
gouverneur
alors Sao Paulo est à la fois
représentatif et un peu une caricature
de ce qui s'est passé c'est-à-dire que
ça au polo c'est probablement l'État qui
est le plus c'était mal prévu par les
sondages ou le vote bolsonaris a été
beaucoup plus haut Addad était donné
comme beaucoup plus haut et ça au polo
c'est vraiment l'exemple de alors que
c'est le cœur du Brésil le cœur battant
économique du Brésil donc très près des
élites comment malgré la proximité
géographique et en partie sociologique
de de la population de cet état
finalement le bolsonarisme s'y est
profondément ancré il faut savoir que
l'intérieur de l'état de Sao Paulo est
extrêmement conservateur et représente
comment le conservatisme traditionnel du
Brésil a finalement embrassé l'extrême
droite embrasser le bolsonarim c'est
accoutumé accoutumé à la violence
verbale et accoutumée à la brutalisation
des relations des relations sociales et
donc effectivement c'est le signe
clair d'une polarisation c'est le signe
aussi de
de l'absence vraiment déco populaire
d'une partie de l'offre de gauche à dad
pourtant un candidat respectable connu
qui a été le représentant de la gauche
en 2018 qui finalement a eu un score
bien sûr des faits mais honorable au
second tour et pris par une vague
d'extrême droite non prévue
relativement récente avec une ascension
très récente et un résultat qui dépasse
complètement les sondages donc sans-paul
et à la fois crucial mais et un
excellent observatoire pour comprendre
ce qu'on ne comprend pas pour comprendre
cette ancrage populaire cette
accoutumance à un discours beaucoup plus
radical que le conservatisme
traditionnel de l'intérieur de l'État
cependant historiquement depuis avant
avant la nouvelle république l'État qui
détermine qui va gagner c'est le
minageiras qui gagne le ménage gerrace
gagne la présidence en général donc il
faudra avoir un regard très porté sur
Sao Paulo mais aussi sur le minage
gérais ou les deux sont complètement au
coude à coude et où il va falloir
observer les logiques parce que il y a
cette idée mais qui est qui de point de
vue de la composition de la population
de l'État a toujours fonctionné qui est
de qui va déterminer qu'elle va être
qu'elle va être le candidat victorieux
un dernier mot pour parler de des
instances locales des résultats au poste
de gouverneur et au-delà des résultats à
la chambre au Sénat il y a quelque chose
qui est très net c'est que l'encrage
populaire du bolsonarisme s'est traduit
par une une solidification de la
représentation politique toutes les
grandes figures du molsonarisme ont été
élus largement élus y compris des
personnages qui étaient des personnages
extrêmement radicaux et qui semblait
avoir été discrédité et donc ça signifie
que quel que soit le résultat du 30
octobre quel que soit le vainqueur du
second tour
même si nous la gagne en d'autres termes
il va avoir un derrière lui comme autre
instance de pouvoir une situation
encore plus conservatrice encore plus
d'opposition que ce qui était le cas en
2018 et ça c'est un risque un risque
politique de paralysie du pouvoir mais
aussi de passage au
semi-présidentialisme qui tirerait
absolument toutes les pouvoirs à la
présidence ou même de destitution parce
que ce qui s'est passé à partir de 2014
c'est des instances législatives
extrêmement contreervatrices qui
n'acceptait absolument pas toute forme
d'agenda progressistes de la part de la
de la présidence et qui a fini par la
destituer donc on a un scénario qui est
compliqué et qui ne doit pas se résumer
à au scrutin présidentiel du 30 octobre
mais aussi à l'ensemble des équilibres
politiques et ceci traduisent un ancrage
profond dans l'électorat mais aussi dans
les instances de représentation d'une
extrême droite qui se naturalise et dont
les propos l'ultra conservatisme l'ultra
individualisme des relations sociales
est complètement naturalisée pour une
partie des élites et aussi pour une
partie des catégories populaires mariage
mariage José mallero ça veut dire que le
bolsonarisme maintenant on peut parler
du bolsonaris comme on peut parler du
trumpisme et ce n'est plus seulement
bolsonaro c'est le bolsonaris
aujourd'hui qui est ancré au Brésil
d'après ce qu'on ce qu'on vient
d'entendre c'est à dire qu'il est
peuples ceux qui à mon avis donne leur
appui à bolsonaro
et c'est un peuple plus grand que vous
c'est large manifestement de parce
qu'elle dit les milieux économiques mais
il y a aussi donc un électorat très
populaire il y a un électorat populaire
il y a les religieux très les
évangélistes Pentecôté et et il y a une
classe moyenne qui a peur parce que ils
ont avalé tous les discours sur la
violence c'est-à-dire en disant la
violence vient de ses côtés là et donc
ces côtés là sont les pauvres sont les
noirs sont ceux qu'on appelle les
minorités donc il y a un discours
raciste qui s'est installé en plus il y
a un discours raciste il faut dire que
aujourd'hui au Brésil un jeune noir
meurt et assassiné à chaque 25 minutes
et
dire ça on ne parle pas tellement on
pense comme les vices des bolsonaro qui
a été celui qui a fait l'intervention à
Rio il y a
j'oubliais comme quelle est la date et
qui donnait l'ordre des tuer comme ça à
partir des hélicoptères on mettrayait la
population dans les favelas on est
supposait pas la question de qui on
était en train de tuer on tué tout le
monde ces pauvres c'est moi donc c'est
pas bon on peut les tuer mais pourtant à
une époque justement il votait Loula
enfin il y avait il y a eu toute cette
période où là qui avait pacifié
d'ailleurs les favelas à l'époque où
semble-t-il donc en fait on est vraiment
passé j'invote encore là quand on dit ah
bonsoir il a beaucoup grandi il faut se
rappeler que aux élections de 2000 2018
bolsonaro a eu 57
des voix cette fois-ci il a eu 51
millions de voix il a perdu 6 millions
de fois et en même temps il est élargi
son électorat à vous écouter c'est un
petit peu ça
électorat du point de vue social et
sociologique donc sociologique bien sûr
mais il ne faut pas dire que le Brésil
devient une nation
facho non ce n'est pas ça il y a la peur
il y a les idées conservatrices et
surtout là avec un sénat un parlement
général qui va être le pire Parlement
très conservateur ce que disait
qu'on aura eu c'est là où Lula va avoir
des difficultés est-ce qu'il va devoir
changer de stratégie justement Lula
Carlos Kenna dans votre avis pour
affronter son adversaire là juste un mot
sur le bolsonarisme si je voulais vous
dire juste un mot en toile de fond de
cette évolution que vous remarquez
c'est-à-dire entre les années loup là et
[Musique]
qui joue et qui ne joue pas forcément
contre bolsonaro j'en viens à votre à
votre question puisque justement en même
temps les facteurs extraits économiques
ont joué un rôle pour et positionner ce
secteur là dans une perspective de
confrontation en considérant que la
faute est à d'autres à d'autres pauvres
à violon et cetera alors nous là
qu'est-ce qu'il doit faire qu'est-ce
qu'il pourrait faire je crois que il y a
eu la une stratégie qui était adaptée à
la situation nouvelle c'est à dire
l'existence d'une force d'extrême droite
importante d'ailleurs l'alliance avec
alkimine qui était
et qui était auparavant et en opposition
à l'eau la deuxième élection disons la
réélection
montrer des gens qui avaient la
perspective d'une alliance très large il
me semble que il n'a pas d'autre choix
que d'insister dans un petit s'adresser
au pdt c'est le parti démocrate
travailliste et chercher à faire
insister beaucoup sur les aspects
démocratiques les dangers qui courent le
Brésil et bien entendu bien entendu et
insistez aussi sur une autre
caractéristique qui a qui est important
chez nous là ce rôle de pacifications la
capacité à gérer une citation complexe
montrer la complexité et la situation
puisque quel que soit celui qui va
gagner le présidentialisme de coalition
qui caractérise le Brésil va être mis en
cause donc ça peut être la stratégie la
bonne stratégie pour la et encore
j'insiste c'est pas sûr que ceci soit il
s'agit colonie de colonie c'est parce
qu'il peut y avoir des facteurs X ou Y
que l'on ne sait pas et que peuvent
intervenir comme la voix les facteurs
ils sont y par exemple la violence voilà
une annonce il faut se rappeler que lors
de l'élection précédente bolsonaro a
diffusé des des informations enfin
toutes les réseaux et disons des sociaux
on diffusé des informations inouïe sur
adave que les enfants allaient être pris
par le candidat le gouvernorat à Sao
Paulo voilà donc là à l'époque donc ça
il ne faut pas exclure et ça peut être
un ingrédient aussi à considérer oui
vous êtes d'accord sur la il y a
beaucoup d'interviens une forme
d'incertitude qui fait qu'effectivement
ça pourrait faire basculer plutôt vers
revenir sur le divorce avec les classes
moyennes alors avant l'élection de 2002
les classes moyennes avait voté assez
massivement pour là ensuite pendant
l'exercice du pouvoir du péter et de
Loula est à travailler un divorce
progressif pourquoi parce que le
gouvernement de Lula a été un
gouvernement très favorable aux
agro-exportateurs d'un côté et au plus
pauvre de l'autre les classes moyennes
et se sont sentis abandonnés d'autant
plus que la politique volontaire de
d'intégration des plus pauvres et en
particulier des afro descendants à
l'université
la loi qui avait été adoptée par à
l'époque de Dilma Rousset pour que la
des personnels domestiques soient
déclarées le Brésil et l'un des pays
avec les pays du Golfe où il y a le plus
de personnels domestiques qui sont empl
des classes moyennes 7 à 8 millions de
personnes en grande majorité des femmes
noires donc il y a eu le sentiment d'une
perte non pas de de revenus mais d'une
perte de valeur symbolique c'est à dire
que comment le fils de Mado mystique va
rentrer à l'université avec mon fils à
l'aéroport où on était entre soi il y a
maintenant des noirs
et je suis obligé
voilà et à partir de là il y a eu un
divorce croissant ce sont des éléments
qui ont pas suffisamment été mis en
valeur et il y a eu un divorce croissant
entre Lula ce que représente Lula le PT
et les classes moyennes c'est ce c'est
ça qu'on retrouve dans l'état de Sao
Paulo qui est l'un des États les plus
riches du Brésil et où donc les emplois
domestiques sont le plus importants ou
le le différentiel symbolique est le
plus important et c'est ce qui est en
train de se jouer effectivement à ce
boulot bon est-ce que
à les moyens de réduire ce fossé dans la
période qui va s'ouvrir d'un mois c'est
peu probable donc je peux revenir à la
question à des projets oui non ça c'est
ça relève de mesures gouvernementales
qui peuvent être prises après les
élections en revanche ce qu'il peut
faire effectivement c'est centrer la
campagne sur la défense de la démocratie
ça pourrait marcher justement votre
chariot une défense de la démocratie par
Lula on a l'impression que c'est déjà un
peu l'axe de sa campagne au premier tour
de défendre la démocratie contre
justement l'autoritarisme de bolsonaro
et la menace justement d'un système qui
tomberait dans fascisme dans le
l'autoritarisme est-ce qu'il devrait
continuer dans cette veine
alors la question de la campagne elle
est très complexe si vous me permettez
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de grandes
incertitudes au-delà des stratégies de
campagne des deux candidats sur ce qui
va se dérouler très concrètement et les
conditions démocratiques de l'antre de
tours comme ça a été dit par les
intervenants il y a la perspective de
l'utilisation massive de fake news mais
il y a la perspective des violences et
bolsonaro et son clan va utiliser toute
la machine de l'État dont il contrôle
une partie en particulier la partie
militarisée ces liens avec les milices
dans les quartiers populaires pour
mettre tout ce poids là dans la dans la
campagne y compris avec très
probablement un des violences ou des
opérations pour terroriser les
populations ou les militants qui
feraient campagnent pour le PT donc
avant de penser quelle serait la
campagne pour gagner le scrutin il va
falloir observer qu'elles vont être les
conditions de la campagne faut savoir
que les milices sont très directement
responsables dans certains quartiers du
vote pour bolsonaro s'ennuyer du tout la
de l'adhésion du conservatisme populaire
j'en ai beaucoup parlé moi j'ai parlé
hier à la femme de ménage qui vient
faire le ménage dans la maison de dans
laquelle je suis hébergé et elle nous a
expliqué que dans la communauté dans la
favela où elle habite il y a une
exigence de la milice qui a été de
nouveau prononcé à l'occasion de cette
élection là sur le fait qu'il fallait
que les 100% pour bolsonaro sinon il y
aurait des conséquences en termes des
rançons qui sont demandés par la
ministre et en termes du prix du gaz et
donc il y a une pression collective qui
est que tout le monde doit voter pour
board bolsonaro sinon la milice locale
va appliquer des sanctions collectives
et tout le monde vote pour bolsonaro et
ça c'est logique de contraintes sociales
qui existent dans des quartiers où
vivent des millions de personnes vont
être mis en plein dans la logique de la
campagne et c'est des choses qu'il va
falloir observer au-delà du discours
bien sûr
c'est ce qui se dit actuellement dans le
secteur progressiste démocratique il va
falloir faire une campagne qui sera une
campagne la plus le possible qui parle
le plus au préoccupations populaires qui
soient une campagne de terrain et pas
une campagne de grand meeting pour
réellement mobiliser la population mais
ça ce ne sera possible que si l'état
actuel l'État fédéral et en la
présidence et toutes ces ramifications
qui sont dans un processus de violence
des relations sociales et politiques
laissent cette campagne se dérouler
d'une manière relativement démocratique
et ça c'est une grande inconnue donc il
faut se rendre compte qu'on n'est pas
exactement dans un contexte démocratique
que l'existence du bolsonarisme au
pouvoir de bolsonaro au pouvoir et de
ses liens avec l'armée avec les polices
militaires et avec les milices a déjà
fait évolué la la situation on n'est pas
simplement dans des manimulations des
opinions avec les fake news pas
simplement avec les manipulations par
les églises des opinions on est aussi
avec des contraintes très concrètes et
des stratégies pour terroriser une
partie des électorats qui se sont déjà
manifestées avant le premier tour et qui
très probablement vont se manifester
entre les il a toute la complexité du
vote pour bolsonaro c'est comprendre à
la fois les vraies raisons sociales pour
lesquelles des gens vont voter en
adhérent à un agenda contervateur autre
personne que j'ai rencontré hier après
je m'arrête une dame qui s'occupe de
surveiller que les voitures sont bien
garées que personne ne va entrer dans
une voiture et qui demande un peu
d'argent pour ça quelqu'un noir
issu de catégories extrêmement
populaires qui nous a dit il faut il
faut pas que Lula soit Élise sinon on va
rendre le pays aux indigènes c'est
quelqu'un qui a connu une modification
de son rapport à la politique qu'il a
fait adhérer à ce type d'idées alors
qu'elle est elle-même noire et d'origine
très populaire donc le bolsonarisme il y
a de l'adhésion il y a de la souffrance
sociale et aussi il y avait un
contrainte de la réaction à la violence
et tout ça va se manifester dans cette
entre-deux tour un entre deux tours donc
à haut risque d'après ce que vous dites
un mot justement sur pour pas parler des
milices simplement est-ce que bolsonaro
s'il perd parce que quand même aussi
encore une chance saison 2 s'il perd
est-ce qu'il pourrait justement dire
qu'il n'a pas perdu et là on se
retrouverait dans un scénario à la Trump
avec potentiel prise du Capitole
brésilien est-ce qu'on peut s'attendre à
cela s'il perd
il a menacé de faire ça la menacé de
faire ça justement
plusieurs à plusieurs reprises il dit
que oui il va rendre le pouvoir à celui
qui gagne mais il faut que ça soit
prouvé que c'est lui qui a gagné a gagné
légalement c'est à dire on peut
comprendre que si ce n'est pas lui qui a
gagné c'est illégal c'est parce qu'il y
a eu des problèmes avec les votes hier
il a déclaré sa confiance sur les
systèmes de vote électronique chose
qu'il a passé un an à discret du thé
maintenant son problème sont les
instituts de sondage alors on ne sait
pas du tout parce que hier il était
presque un pleure quand il a parlé aux
personnes devant lui
pour dire
s'il rend ou s'il les rend pas le
pouvoir on ne peut pas savoir il est
imprévisible donc c'est un scénario
qu'on ne peut pas exclure en tout cas
non
oui vous êtes d'accord oui on peut rien
exclure et d'autant plus que quand on
l'a dit disons et quoi qu'il fasse il y
a et dans ces éléments démolitionnalisme
dont on a donné toutes les dimensions
qui sont complexes et il y en a même
d'autres et une idée que celui qui a
raison quoi qu'ils disent quoi qu'il
fasse un peu à la Trump et d'ailleurs
les choses qui peuvent paraître
complètement exagérées ou un ridicule
sont considérées parfois comme temps
plus plus véritable que les choses
raisonnables donc je pense qu'on peut
pas exclure et là on pourrait entrer
dans une zone de turbulance importante
et puisque nous ne parlons pas d'un
petit pays nous parlons d'un pays qui
est le plus important de la navigatine
entière la population 40% du PIB et avec
une influence certaine dans les affaires
régionales et internationales donc ça
serait effectivement une sorte de de
passage à quelque chose là on sortirait
de la démocratie pour le coup c'est
effectivement bolsonaro conteste le
scrutin si le père bon sortir de la
démocratie dans le style des années
70-80 du siècle passé non en revanche on
peut imaginer toutes sortes de
manipulations y compris après les
élections de style de celle dont a été
victime la présidente d'ilma Rousseff
dans la mesure où il a une majorité
parlementaire donc on peut imaginer un
troisième tour entre guillemets reposant
sur une manipulation constitutionnelle
mais ça n'exclut pas non plus comme
disait Carlos Kenan tout à l'heure
quelque chose
d'énorme ou quelque chose ou une un
contexte de violence qui soit invoquée
pour
suspendre le décompte des résultats ou
on peut imaginer toutes sortes de
scénarios dans la mesure où depuis un an
le président sortant conteste la
transparence des élections la validité
des élections que cette contestation a
été relayée par un certes son ministre
de la Défense en général par un certain
nombre de militaires on l'oublie mais
qui ont obtenu d'avoir l'un d'entre eux
au sein du Tribunal Supérieur électoral
qui est quand même on commence pas très
bien quels sont les qualités
de connaissance du droit électoral ayant
justifié cette mesure sinon un rapport
de force à l'intérieur des institutions
les militaires d'ailleurs ils ont voté
pour lui aussi là au premier tour vous
pensez les militaires
les militaires soutiennent le tiers du
gouvernement actuel est composé par des
officiers généraux le vice-président est
un général un décompte parallèles est
effectué par les militaires donc là il y
a là effectivement un facteur
d'incertitude sur lequel peut jouer
bolsonaro en s'appuyant sur une argutie
juridique du même type de celle qui ont
été opposées à la présidente pour la
destituer ce qui a constitué un
véritable coup d'État parlementaire donc
coup d'État possible incertitude en tout
cas c'est le mot qui revient et ça sera
effectivement le mot de la fin merci
beaucoup Jean-Jacques rourianski d'avoir
été avec nous merci à vous Carlos Kenan
merci mode chirio d'avoir été avec nous
en direct de Rio Merci à VOUS mariage
osé Malraux et puis merci à Fanny Lother
qui a ouvert ce débat notre
correspondante France 24 à Rio merci à
vous tous de nous avoir suivis et restez
avec nous sur France 24
[Musique]